you ever have something going on and you
wonder is it allergies or is it a cold
opt-in care lung and allergy care the
sponsor of this segment wants to help
you determine what your symptoms mean
rocky spoke with the doctor to learn
more
now many of us have the question is it
allergies or is it a cold can you help
us out with that sure
very common question
and very timely how cold usually you
feel sick there's a defined period of
time you feel sick you get stuffy don't
feel good sometimes you have a fever and
then you get better traditionally in one
to two weeks
when you have allergy like problems it's
usually there is a pattern okay you're
not sick but you're bothered by some
symptoms stuff it's just easy running
and it's usually there's a pattern of
sometimes in the year or when you're
around certain things so that's the
biggest difference between
thinking that you may have allergies
versus a cold
okay and and some of this would be
called um
non-allergic rhinitis right
correct because not everything is
allergies correct so if you have stuffy
itchy sneezy runny
training at the back of the throat
a lot of people will think automatically
i must be allergic to something in
reality
it's not all allergies and a substantial
amount of the symptoms that you feel
is due to things other than allergies
okay so then let's talk about some
examples of those symptoms so people
understand what's happening
sure most of these symptoms are when
when it when it's
non-allergic usually there are two prime
primary symptoms you're stuffy and you
have drainage at the back of your throat
you're always
clearing your throat
if it's allergies
usually there's accompanying sneezing
itchy runny nose or watery itchy eyes
and there is certain certain patterns to
the times of the year
and if you don't have allergies it's
usually all year round and what you hear
is the things that trigger me are things
like changes in the weather
various scents and odors potpourri
candles perfumes smoke
these are examples of things that are
not allergies there's the top three
things that are not allergic
from the bottom is bad reflux
not a lot of people know that reflux or
heartburn the acid can cause
drainage and stuffiness
second thing is if there's something
wrong with your nose if there's a
deviated septum if there's a blockage
for children big tonsils and adenoids
that back up the phlegm
and then the number one thing other than
allergies that causes it that causes the
symptoms is what we call vasomotor
rhinitis now what's that transient
medical term mean
instead of alder gins
like cat dog pollen
it's irritants so let's talk about
diagnosis and how to treat rhinitis
correct
so
let's say you have a history that you're
you don't know if you have allergies or
not okay
the most important thing is to test and
there are two kinds of testing there is
the blood testing and then there is the
skin testing
and by far the more reliable test is the
skin test
we want to thank optum care lung and
allergy care for sponsoring this segment
they have locations across southern
nevada if you want more information you
can call that phone number 702-724-8844
or visit optumcare.com
in the lung